all right patrick we're on
we're on welcome back good to see you
good to see you hello everybody
out there so this is a very different
patrick
i hope so than the one who's been here
three times before
since the last time you were here our
last video you you checked yourself into
a rehab
right after that's right and how's that
been
uh so i've been clean since then um so
that was like
right around a month ago um so i'm clean
now
i'll say this and this this feeling came
immediately upon us agreeing to do this
last week
um like doing this
and being like you know captain honest
like uh like like i've been in the past
is a whole different story clean uh
versus high on crack
you know like there's there's
nervousness and fear
at a much higher level right now so that
that honesty that you
showed in those other talks was from
your well no you know my goal
is to be just as honest now because i do
i do believe and actually i believe even
more from the experience of doing this
that that there's power in that and that
somewhere
in that lies the power to to finally
overcome this thing
um so i'm convinced of that yeah it's
it's it's
there's so much gosh now i'm realizing
there's so much we could talk about
um when it comes to that you know when
it comes to what there is to overcome
this thing
and uh and how i kind of just stumbled
in here accidentally
it would appear but i don't believe that
you know and decided that first time to
just go for it
in a crack crack haze um so yeah so
there's a different there's a higher you
do
i think it takes more courage right now
uh more
you know that old that that thing that's
always there when i'm clean
across you know definitely the last
several years of my life
of trying to present an image of some of
someone better than i think i
am right like the imposter so i want to
sound good
want to say the right things want to
make sure to leave out the things that i
think would be
like embarrassing things and uh and i've
already said all those embarrassing
things on the last few videos if anyone
had to watch those they could just
go back and watch those goodness um so
anyway there's that
uh turns out a lot of people watch your
channel i discovered like a lot of
understanding
like most of my friends
like i have i have awesome friends i
have so many people that love me
uh it's like almost seems unfair you
know
last night i was with like my inner
circle of friends you know like with the
people that
i hang out with the most over these last
couple years
over my buddy's house and uh we were
talking about this we're talking about
you know the life talking about what
some of the things i went through
and i'm not going to mention anybody's
name but those people are so
awesome and so dear to me and uh and
they treat me
as though like nothing ever happened
that's the thing that's like
and you know i met everybody all of them
through the 12 steps and narcotics
anonymous and
that sort of love and friendship um
you know it's it's remarkable um it
helps me
not feel the depression that i am
experiencing you know
so um
how about i how about i recap like what
happened since the last video
yeah so i remember
the last video i think you took you
drove me to my apartment
after three or four hours after getting
mugged over here you know
and then uh so i didn't stop using for
like at least another week
after that um and i did some and i did
some awful things
in that you know i just i did some
hurtful things to people and i'm going
to tell you about those right here um
as soon as i got home right in that next
day or two
um my mom came you know my mom's the
other one i should mention that
i've spent the last three days with her
and she's absolute angel
you know like uh
you know i don't deserve it you know
it's funny like we we
like sometimes it seems like we get what
we need although maybe not like maybe a
lot of people not it seems like for some
reason i've always had what i've needed
no matter
if it's if i'm earning it myself or if
what i don't have that ability
and i was actually joking with my mom
because one thing that my brother and i
have yet to provide her with which she
would want are grandchildren
you know for various reasons and i joked
with her i think yesterday that
well at least uh we're not giving you
grandchildren but we are giving you
well i at least i'm giving you you know
uh
a life that needs a parent for 50 years
instead of the usual 20.
and she laughed and also had watery eyes
over that but she came over to my
apartment
to help me because it was becoming clear
that i was gonna have to move out of
that apartment
um and we were gonna try to go to impact
i think we talked about that yesterday
at length on that day um and
to get into that place i was told that
the way to do that is to call every day
you know and so i was just in just a
total depression
not allowing to move and you know coming
down off of that experience with with
the drugs
and doing very little you know like i
should have done way more i was letting
my mom do a lot
you might clean my whole apartment
started like sort of organizing it
getting boxes
you know getting like moving i'm getting
ready to move out um
and on the sunday of the end of that
week it was going to be the
like a u-haul was we're gonna come with
my brother my dad and we're gonna
put the furniture and be done with that
apartment
and so on the saturday evening prior to
that sunday
you know i'm sitting there and i have a
way to get money again
right i have a way to get money again
i'll go into that after and
in my in my head it was like this is the
last chance you have
to get high right getting high in the
next crack hit was still the
most important thing and i was sitting
there like going through those days with
my mom there
and i just felt awful you know like like
the only antidote like
is to get high and so
you know i told my mom i was going to
the liquor store
you know which was literally like the
first time i left her her
you know she even asked me can i take
you like no let me go you know
and i come down here i get i got to lift
i come down skid row i get crack
and i go back home to her wood crack
because like
even though my mom is sacrificing first
driving from arizona
to come and help me like it's more
important that i get high
it's what i consider possibly the last
chance i had to do it
you know but then before i got back over
there she knew
you know like like it's not like oh i
wonder what i was taking so long i just
and so you know one of her things is
like she'll do anything for me
anything no matter what it is but but
not except
be around me when i'm getting high like
she won't and so
she was like she asked me like throw
dump it
which i wasn't gonna do that so she took
off you know and i proceeded to get high
throughout the night of my last
day in my apartment and then i wasn't
sure what was gonna even happen then
now you know like that was like a change
of plans with you know
there he goes um but they still did come
with the u-haul and i had like what i
probably the worst day of my life you
know maybe
of going out of that place where i've
always been trying to hide from all my
neighbors
you know like in the using times in the
clean times i'm just like a normal
neighbor try to hide you know i'm always
afraid they're gonna know what i'm doing
and now we're moving out and i'm high
and i'm scared my dad is there it was
awful
and so basically like running away from
that place having not paid the rent
you know and uh winding up at my
brothers
and now it's like okay now you don't
have an apartment or a car you know like
and i still had access to money and i
was i remember
that my brother was thinking like
there's only one thing
like like you need crack more than
you've ever needed it before
at this point with having to deal with
all that
and so i lifted from there you know
did went to pomona for one night getting
high
um came home back to his place
took off again and it was i was like
sneaking away i didn't have to even do
that i could
well maybe with my parents but like with
my brother i could just tell him hey man
i know you probably don't agree but i'm
going to get hired he wouldn't he
wouldn't stop me
yeah but instead of doing that i'm like
you know check this out i'll tell you
this is ridiculous
uh instead of doing that normal thing
like hey bro he probably would have even
helped me like instead of
maybe hey man will you please just drop
me off instead of doing a lift i don't
know but
instead of that i'm in the his garage
like smoking a cigarette like wearing
like pajama pants
and slippers and like he has his shoes
in the garage i get a pair of his shoes
and i go out to the lips and i come down
here in pajama pants
right and
check into a a hotel down here
or i got kicked out of that hotel the
the next day
um so here's another story so so this is
so now i'm back down here
like six days after the
after that incident happened over right
around the corner here
and people knew you know i was back
wearing pajama pants smoky track like
here again and uh but i did have a hotel
so i had a hotel out of skid row down
down central like ways down there
but i'll kind of come up here to score
and everything um
and so i was at that hotel let me tell
you this story
um still calling impact every day still
like managing
to make that call so that almost like so
that i could say i did
right like i never broke the street in
all this that i'm doing i'm squeezing in
a call
to them and they're not getting back to
me they're checking your insurance
or whatever whatever it probably didn't
matter because if they would have said
okay come on in
i wouldn't have none of i would still
had a chance to keep getting high but i
was doing that
and i was at this hotel over here and uh
you know i was you know i've described
how i am when i take a crack hit
and so you know i did some creepy i did
some creepy stuff you know not like
dangerous
not but like uh
uh in the morning you know six in the
morning
i take a crack hit in that motel room
and get all you know sexed up
and horny and like fantasy world comes
and i go downstairs to like the worker
girl that works at the
like works at the motel you know and
like invite her to my room basically
yeah like if she wants to come up on her
break or whatever and she was cool about
it like
no no thanks bro like like i don't take
breaks you know and i and okay i walk
away five minutes after that
in my room you know wears off and i'm
just like mortified like oh my god
that's why i call the hotel knowing
she'll answer and she answers and i
apologize
you know like very like i'm so sorry
that was out of line i shouldn't have
done that
you know please forgive me and she was
really cool about it yeah no problem man
so then like you know soon after that
like the maid who comes and cleans the
rooms you know so i would maybe take a
hit and like
be attracted to her but it was like i
didn't really like
know what to say to her but just you
know i was just around too much you know
um so to speed up this part of the story
i
i um i get the room for another night
you know going back to that same girl
but
four hours later no problem yeah she's
paid for the second night whatever
i come down here for a few hours like i
didn't even go back up to my room i went
paid for the next night
came here did my thing when i want to
back down there at like two o'clock
um i finally get in touch with impact
like there's a message on my phone like
hey call us back here call me back where
the guy was
and uh calling back and i'm on the phone
with him i'm literally on the phone with
them when i
knock knock knock on the door of my room
and it's like the owner of the place
like telling me i have to leave
immediately
with like the two girls behind him like
you have to leave immediately
your uh whatever doing whatever to the
to the staff
making her uncomfortable you know um
i'm telling him like hey like i'm on the
phone man you gotta wait till i'm off
this
this call um anyway
i wound up arguing with this guy like
okay you want me to leave fine just
refund me the second day
you know i wasn't even here like i was
literally just got back half an hour ago
no we're not refunding you the second
day and i wind up like
downstairs like where they have like
their little side office and i'm like
the the the nature of that argument was
that he wouldn't let me say anything
every time i start to talk he yells you
know one point has a baseball bat like
up to my neck
that thing we're calling the cops he
said we're calling the cops and you're
gonna get arrested
all right fine call the cops you go back
up to my room
and they they've locked me out you know
so all my stuff's in there
uh i'm locked out and so i did i've
never done this in my life and i was
sort of proud of myself for succeeding
on my first attempt but i just
threw the door and busted it open with
my shoulder
and broke it and uh like a movie
kind of yeah like how cops would do it
if they were trying to get in i mean i
guess the door's just flimsy because
it'd be like oh it broke just the right
amount like not terribly broken but an
open and whatever i told me you knocked
me out of there
you know no that's not yeah so the cops
became and i was
i wasn't worried at all about the cops
coming i feel like i understand
their their approach to like
users and stuff and honesty i even told
him the owner like hey man
i'm a drug addict otherwise i wouldn't
be at your motel like i'm
not a news flash to any to you or anyone
else down here
and yeah i'll admit sometimes i you know
i get
high i act a little bit inappropriate
like i apologize to your worker here she
was fine with it she like bought
she got my second night payment no
problem
um and so when the police came it was
like a guy and a girl in a patrol car
and like so the guy wanted my story and
then the girl
was talking to him like i just told him
all the truth like i'm a drug addict you
know i'm here
this to happen this happened uh he wants
me to leave but
he's he's not giving me a refund so so
the end result of that was
uh okay he's gonna give you a refund but
please leave
no problem like that's what i told him
in the beginning that would have been
so that that happened um
you know from there i just you know ran
out the clock for the next couple days
until there was no money
now here's another awful thing that uh
you know me being high it caused me to
do um what happened with impact though
oh so at that moment um
i wasn't gonna like there was so much
going on you know there's so much going
on so basically
with what impact was telling me was here
go to this other program
and i'm not sure exactly what why but i
have a feeling it had to do with
immediate help being necessary because i
told the guy on the phone
exactly what i was doing where i was and
he was like oh wow like
well that's refreshing to hear you be so
honest but like call this number and so
it was a different place
it was a place i could go to immediately
they offered to uh
just tell me where you are right now and
we'll come pick you up right
and so i once everything kind of settled
and i got back to looking at the phone
and figuring that out
i wasn't going to call because i still
had the chance to keep getting high
so basically i called that number i
called that guy
like the next like one day later uh
late at night and uh that and i was at
the end
um i ran out of money
that i was um basically i had a friend
and i think i mentioned it briefly in
past interviews uh
really a dear friend she's great and
excuse me and she was basically
like feeding me money as like almost
like an advance on my tax return
which i had sent her the debit card for
the tax returns that she would have that
when it came
so then in between my last time seeing
you
and my mom coming down somewhere in
those days the tax return came
and i still had access to it like
without even having the card physically
and i literally spent it all like
drained it down to zero
they sort of referred me to another
place and i think i don't know it
doesn't really matter now but
pretty sure the reason was this other
place could offer me immediate help
in fact they um they told me just tell
us tell us where you are and we'll come
to you right now take you
take you into rehab immediately and so i
didn't do that
for another day until i rent completely
ran out of money um
but at that point did do that and they
that offer was still available and so i
wound up
doing a like a 30ish day treatment
program in the valley
which which wound up being a place to to
sleep and eat
and not take drugs it's basically like
the
what was accomplished there the way i
was getting all this money
uh you know involved me basically
robbing my friend
yeah a girl that had like base that she
had been you know
feeding me money over time because she's
nice and she loves me and i asked her
and uh i had a tax return coming in the
future which i always thought was going
to be
way in the future of all this using you
know because this started in december
and then like this time around they
didn't start doing taxes until like late
february
uh so i had mailed her the debit card
that that tax return was going to
and then you know before like before i
was out of my apartment
you know i see on my phone oh your
money's there and i had a way of getting
that money like around the back door
without having the card and i literally
spent it all
you know so leaving her with nothing um
just you know one of the things um
you know i went to that uh rehab center
and took your they took my phone away
for a week
you know which is common actually that's
usually would be longer it seems like
this place is a little bit
easier going um and just like another
example of how
awesome my friends are to me you know i
told her
the day i got my phone back i told her
you know what what i did
and she was basically like you know
you're fine i love you like i'm glad
you're in rehab
don't worry we'll work it out i don't
want to pay her back you know but
that was that was the that was i tell
her that and her response is like i love
you
it gets cool you gotta get it yeah she's
awesome so
so yeah um that's what happened
um there was a moment
you know i got the the last night of
using was was
awful but it just i mean that's probably
common
i'm realizing that i'm getting towards
broke and i'm so far gone and
and uh like more and more people are
starting to
you know text me like the link to this
video last time like what's going on man
was you know
people are calling me and calling me i'm
running out of money i was in a place i
really didn't feel comfortable with the
person i
kind of didn't want to be around but i
was stuck there because we kept getting
high getting high
you know and i finally got out there and
i was walking
so i had to walk you know probably like
a mile a mile and a half
to go one last place with like the last
60 bucks but it was like
more of a friendly environment and uh
crying at one point i'm walking and i'm
crying and i was down there on imperial
kind of like
more west than normal and there's a spot
i didn't realize where i was going
down imperial the street crosses the
freeway
i didn't realize that it was going to
happen when i figured but i was
you know and i'm crying somehow i
started like bawling
as i'm walking across the freeway you
know and i look up like oh the fence is
just like not
you know i could boo boom go over it
fall down on the freeway
you know and normally i get to that
state i get that deep
and those sort of ideas will be there
it's almost like my
like i don't call it voices but it's
like
it's like multiples like my brain my
it's almost like my voice it's almost
like
my brain having a conversation with
itself but two-sided you know and
go do it jump no you know almost like
they talk about
the disease of addiction like like uh
kind of like when you're clean i'll tell
you come on do it come on do it
you know you deserve it you don't get
high and as soon as you do it you're a
piece of [ __ ] like the same thing like
that
so i looked up there um
but as i was looking up there and as of
that whole thing i was processing the
fact like oh you're on a bridge
you know like i knew i wouldn't do it i
even felt like
my feet like get heavier down onto the
ground for whatever whatever that is
uh so i continued on and and i
and i wound up in that place
i didn't do much you know um i feel like
my past
time is getting clean which ever been
you ended up in the rehab yeah so i'm
now in rehab so so from
from uh you know end of february through
i got out
three days ago um i feel like past times
getting clean which there's dozens
i've been more active like more like
trying to do
recovery you know trying to do things to
get the ball rolling again striving
this time uh not necessarily on purpose
but just
whatever like like uh depressed like a
lot of uh
laying on my bed a lot of sleeping a lot
of watching tv
you know checking out a lot of eating a
lot of eating
um you know so
so let's talk about that so then it's
also the fact
that i did these videos right and so
man um and there's the two sides of
honesty
you know there's like the
kind of like the fear side like what i
would always have all my life was this
fear
of saying it saying everything you know
especially the sexual stuff
you know especially those details you
know um
and then i stumbled in here and said all
the details
you know i went from like you know
nobody knowing
or maybe a couple two three people right
that's the people you trust the most the
people that are like
willing to be honest with you about that
stuff too and i kind of skipped like
in the middle part went out to like you
know whoever wants to log on
and watch it um you thought you were
just talking to me but you're talking
yeah no i didn't i kind of you know my
mind knew what this was going to be and
then i especially knew
ever since that first one came out right
and when that first one first came out
this is way back you know i still had a
lot of
smoke cracks of smoke after that first
one um
i uh i did have like a negative reaction
like oh man
i'm done yeah like i'm done
because i've always had this
you know hide the bad [ __ ] like like uh
imposter syndrome like you know present
yourself
um and having this experience
like you know in a way it's like like
there's like a freedom side of it you
know i've had a couple people a few
people
um help me to have a different idea of
it
like like this is what you need like
this is gonna cause people to love you
even more right to like
to know all this right to have this out
there
um because you talked about it i watched
the third one
uh yesterday i hadn't seen it watch it
for the first time you talked about
love being the thing self-love and then
for us addicts choosing choosing to fix
instead of love and i believe that
choosing fear yeah and
whatever's missing you know whatever's
missing um
you know like i would use the word
perverted and disgusting
and gross and like those sort of
actually describe what i do
and like how i am and friends you know
like although one friend in particular
that saw
it seems like certain people subscribe
in my
my different friend circles certain
people subscribe to your channel
and they're just they just subscribe to
your channel and then all of a sudden
i'm on there
and then next thing you know like
everyone you know it kind of goes from
one yeah
to 50. and so on um
but certain people like making it like
it's okay
you know like you're not gross like
you're actually not even that much
different
no i think you're always i think i'm i'm
all in my life kind of like
subconsciously thinking like you're
gross you're different hide it
right so that's one thing that happened
from this is uh
you know especially especially with
women you know you know because i would
it'd be easier for me to
tell the truth to a dude than to a woman
because i think like you know women are
the ones
women are the ones you're trying to
impress or that for whatever reason i
think that they would be the ones to
find this really extra disgusting or
what have you
and no like they know at least not all
of them
and they're they're happy to see me
being honest
and they tell me things like uh you know
you can love yours what if you just love
yourself and accepted that like that
stuff that i do that's part of my
addiction right that's
that's part of it and it's not
necessarily gross you know i told uh
you know i was at that uh that rehab
and probably the best thing i think the
reason i went there i feel like
everything happens for a reason and uh
there was one
uh counselor that would come in three
times a week
and um and she helped me
she was good she wound up she you know
she got sober years ago
um but kind of in a public way like like
i won't go into that but
um and on our last group the last
group that i had with her and the other
there's only like three or four other
clients there
um we watched my first video
as like part of the group you know yeah
we actually
we watched one of her videos this this
counselor which was like a ted talk
she's you know stayed sober for years
and so yeah
and then we watched that and it was a
little bit like who
you know and we just watched it and um
she went up telling me right when it was
over like you're gonna stay clean now
because of this because of that honesty
and like breaking through that barrier
even though it was like
not the plan you know it kind of
happened by accident
um that's what she that was her takeaway
and she was
as she cried and told me she loved me
more right
and then talked about like some stuff
she went through that would be kind of
like way out there
like the super honest edge of the scale
and then
one of the one of my you know colleagues
who have other patients in there this
older dude said hey could i say
something and told something that he had
never shared in his life
you know so like the spear of honesty
was there in that
you know almost like they watch that and
they're like well okay let me let me do
it too
so that was powerful i think i think
your honesty
makes you perhaps the most loved person
on my channel
because you're just so incredibly honest
and vulnerable
yeah i mean it's it's more of an effort
today but but it's the right way to be
i think it makes you you know it
the end result is the exact opposite of
what you think you think everyone is
going to be horrified and hate you
yeah and it's the exact opposite
everyone relates to you and loves you
right yeah like the the great majority
and i do
i have read the comments for them for i
think most of them
like i haven't done that in a while but
when i was like home depressed in
between getting high i
especially the first video i read a lot
of the comments and
it's it's that's remarkable how many
people you know thank you all of you
people that like
want me to do good and feel for me
but like human nature you know maybe how
do you think like 10
of them are negative maybe or something
like small there's always some
percentage
yeah and i focus on those right like
it's my nature my answer is
to pick those apart but i remember all
the negatives to resist yeah to resist
trying
like like uh correcting them where
they're wrong and everything and um
one thing i'll say about that the
negative one
did i see myself in that like i could i
could be the negative guy
watching anything like oh yeah so great
but what about that what about that
and uh one thing about the negative
comments it seemed to me
um they're always so sure of themselves
yes
right negative comments or statements of
like this is absolutely the truth
is a fact yeah like it's like of course
how could you possibly know
but they don't and that that's when you
know it's gonna do a negative comment
try to use some nuance and don't pretend
you know for sure so just suggest
something
that maybe i'm lying that's a great
observation so what's your plan from
here okay so
uh that you know that's one thing that's
different now versus any of the times in
the past is that
so like as i've described over these
times my car the car's been gone
good job turns out you're not supposed
do you still have the job i do still
have the job
um it's incredible the apartment's gone
all the money's gone
um so it was like what part of money and
cars are all replaceable what to do yeah
sure i mean it doesn't matter one thing
is like okay no matter how much money i
make
if it's going to turn in if it's going
to be zero or like let's call what it is
negative 20 grand whatever it is right
now
uh every time then it probably doesn't
matter how much money i made
before that right that doesn't matter
but the job is still there
basically i've been on medical leave
they know what's going on
they you know your teeth you're still a
handsome guy nobody's
nobody's removed any fingers from you
but i had but it was like what do you do
now
you know you don't have that apartment
to go back to you you're like i can't
really work without having a car to get
there having some setup no money to
start
to move into a place so we're looking at
sober livings
places that the insurance would cover
like first month stuff like that
um so where do you stand as an addict
today so you've been you've been in this
rehab for about a month right
and you seem perfectly you seem as sober
as a judge right now
but is there a temptation to use again
not right now uh that's something i
could talk about that
so the last uh time that i had the
obsession to use
it was um i can't remember exactly where
how many days i had been at the rehab
but i definitely had my phone again
so probably like 10 days in roughly
and for i can't remember exactly what it
was but some detail of what i saw on my
phone made me think oh i can get money
again
something happen at my bank or something
and so i already went to one rehab and
left
before the third video and that now i'm
laying there
i'm laying in bed i'm thinking about it
thinking about like
all the steps that it would require pack
your stuff tell
tell the staff guy hey i'm leaving which
whatever they have they can't keep you
there
get get it get a lift uh
go and come straight down here boom i'm
laying there i want to do it
i want to do it and i'm laying there and
i'm laying there and
eventually you know what i see what
happened that night i made a couple
friends
that i've met in person but they're what
they're viewers
and i've made a couple friends a couple
that i've like that i've stayed in touch
with them through the comments
i know we have we've got each other's
info so yeah through the comments but
no you know they people find me on
facebook or myself right now yeah
and i was talking to one of them you
know that nice
person that just wants me to to succeed
and uh
and i wound up texting with her like
sort of like like
accidentally at that moment and all of a
sudden like an hour of that
maybe went by or some amount of time
texting back and forth and like
i forgot that i wanted to go get high
and then
from the next morning until now i
haven't thought about it
i haven't like thought it would have
wanted to or could or
schemed on how i could and that's rather
that's kind of normal for me
like that's my pattern would be to get
like this and what would trigger it
yeah that's down the road and so
triggering it would be like going back
to work getting back into like the
hustle and bustle of everyday life
um feeling lonely perhaps
going and visiting prostitutes clean and
then feeling shame over that
kind of like that whole way of thinking
of myself like the whole
perverted disgusting stuff um
maybe doing that three or four times but
in a real sort of addict have you ever
had a girlfriend
yeah i've had girlfriends a few over the
years
i would think that would keep you clean
right yeah that's that's been discussed
over time here and there as the
one of the strategies like get a
girlfriend like i mean it seems like a
go help you know like that would make me
feel more uh like times when i've had a
girlfriend i felt better about myself
yes i'm saying
yeah so that's that's a thing and
um and then eventually though realizing
that the prostitute behavior
um just isn't fulfilling and then really
what i want
is crack my one of my old sponsors would
call
like describe prop for me not for
everybody but for me prostitute walking
down sidewalk
that's a crack pipe walking down the
sidewalk that's how he would describe it
so right when i so one thing that
happened um
when i got my phone back at the rehab i
turn it on
there's a long email right from a dear
friend of mine
that uh that i lived with for a year in
puerto rico right and this guy
is like the puerto rican version of me
right this guy's hilarious and
smart i love this guy and uh he's
describing in his email
how and he lived in florida how he just
went through
he relapsed last year for the first time
in like eight years i think first time
in a while
whatever whatever stories i've told you
ten times heavier you know he had a lot
of money to blow through
and just blew it up like lost his losses
lost his business lost his marriage lost
everything
and was gonna kill himself right and
then so
and then uh decided sort of at the last
minute
um to go back to teen challenge
like the program where we were the
program that i worked for and then back
in massachusetts
and so he'd been there for he'd been
there five months and he saw my video
right so that's really what generated
this emails he sees the video
right and so that tells him
how i'm doing you know and he's
basically like
come here you know come here hang out
with me
you know let's do this let's get let's
get to get let's let's recover together
let's get strong again
uh i love this guy and i want to finally
call it him at first when i saw that
you know that goes against one of the
things i've been trying to do these last
five six years which is like cling to
this life independent life
like this like regular job apartment
like a regular like a regular person
um and then i wound up calling and
talking to my boss
you know like like my boss like my the
guy that runs the place where i work is
a
special guy and i have a great
relationship with him and i
and i i totally trust his advice and his
judgment he's like a father figure to me
and i told him i asked him like for help
making the decision you know
do i stay try to find a spot come back
to work
or you know my friend that i just the
puerto rican friend
um was the first one that pitched the
idea to me of like asking for a leave of
absence from work
and going there that would be a six
month uh
six month program in massachusetts so um
i i presented that to my boss like i
asked him what he thought and
immediately it was like
i think the sixth month sounds good you
know i'll do whatever i can to
to support you on that you know who
knows if the league of absence will be
approved i
already turned in um requests for that
um
and and so i made that decision to do
that
to like fly to massachusetts go into
that place
as soon as i made that and it was like
sort of surreal that day you know as
soon as i talked to my boss and like
that was like the final straw for me
for to make the decision and that day
was
it was it was almost like i was outside
of my body
watching myself do this thing is it
difficult for you to make that
because you seem fine now and my
temptation if i were in your shoes would
be
like no i'm good right i'm good that's
what i've always done leave me alone
because i do feel good
like i probably could go to work
tomorrow yeah and be i would just go
back to work and yeah forget i've always
done that
i've always done that i do that would be
better you know start making money
to start digging out this hole yeah but
that's
all the material stuff and feel like
that sort of uh
pride or you know like whatever whatever
it is that makes me feel bad about
myself
as an addict or even as a human i think
i'll try to get anything from anywhere
to make me feel better and so is my
performance at work it's my relationship
with co-workers it's my income
you know um and right now it's nothing
like
like i've so i don't know i don't really
feel at this moment
you know i think like another part of
addiction is self-centeredness and so
here i am
talking about myself so this is well
farming my favorite thing to do is like
i'm always thinking about myself and
talking about myself
you're just as lovable in this state to
me as you
would be if you had a car and a job in
an apartment and
agree thank you for that and that's true
because otherwise it wouldn't be love
if they depended on having a car and all
that it would be some other thing not
love
love is something that i think you're a
great guy many other people yeah
but it still remains true that i'm like
technically homeless you know
penniless you know all those that is my
status right now as far as you know
describe the describe the uh
well i'm going to take care of you as i
always do here sure you won't
there's no chance of you using that on
no we'll talk i'll show you no not at
all
my dear friend that brought me down here
will help with that if there was
anything
on that end so i came down here uh with
another uh i would hate
a clean addict in recovery so that's
good
um but but there was an immediate like
sort of depression that set in right
away after making that decision
and i felt like it was like i was
grieving um
that i finally had to let go of
the clinging to this life like like
clinging to like this material things
and being this
this guy you know being this kind of
this person the successful person
that i would always try to portray
myself as um
and that's probably healthy you know
that's you know they talk about like
surrender
and letting go and like what am i you
know when they talk about like the third
step
in the program of like turning your will
and life over the care of god
you know however you see god um
someone described that back in the day
as jumping off a cliff
you know it's like you're jumping off a
cliff just trusting that you're out
you're gonna something's gonna catch you
instead of like trying to build a
skyscraper at the top of the cliff
i'm jumping off um so so i do feel like
i went through a little bit of a
grieving process and it is still
true that i would you know like to like
today hopefully like after this
hopefully it's not too long before i'm
like laying down vegging out
watching tv again like like i'm watching
billions right now which is fantastic
um so so yeah
so i was gonna go um tomorrow
i had i had the flight booked for
for a red eye tomorrow night um
but one thing i have to do and i've
mentioned this i think i mentioned in
passing but i had cancer
i had melanoma twice in my life already
it was on my head i have like you could
see this on my head and then
two and a half years later in 2016 it
came back
here in my lymph nodes there's two lumps
there's two cancer tumors melanoma
in my lymph nodes and so i had to get
surgery to get them out
having that going through that while i
worked at this job
probably helped me do a few extra
relapses
and come back without saying anything
because because i was getting cancer
treatment
after i had the after i had the tumors
taken off
i did three years of infusions at the
city of hope
to try to try to reduce the chances of
it coming back
and i have to continuously go and get
scanned get checked you know every it
was every three months now it's every
six months
and so i got in there a couple days ago
because i wanted to get in there before
i went
like before i went to massachusetts and
before my insurance cuts off because my
insurance is also
going to cut off due to this decision
and
the scans found two things uh something
in my neck
and that had something in my liver and
that's never
there was one time like a couple years
ago we weren't sure and i had to do a
biopsy but that one was clean
so this is only the second time that
there's ever been anything
that requires anything extra and so um
especially the one in my neck they would
want to at least
like the least amount of time they would
want me to wait would be six weeks
to look again see if it grew because
basically these things are growing
since the last time beyond just beyond a
threshold of
worry yeah so
because of what's going on i'm gonna do
i'm doing the biopsy immediately
right so i'm doing a biopsy uh on monday
um so that threw everything sort of into
so i'm having a biopsy on that monday
wait for the results to come back
and um hopefully it's negative and then
i go
but that's what's going on um that's the
latest
so i just found that out on monday yeah
i don't know i wish you the best
that's a little scary i i you know yeah
i mean you're right it's interesting
people always ask me how did you take
the news you know
um and my boss like my boss my former
direct supervisor who's retired now
would always marvel at how my attitude
was about the cancer
because it's the same as it is now like
i'm not worried
you know like it's like whatever
and i feel like the reason i'm like that
because of the addiction
like this addiction thing is so gnarly
and so
overwhelming that any other thing is
like nothing in comparison
like for for cancer for the cancer thing
i gotta get a covet test on sunday and i
gotta go to get a biopsy on monday so i
basically have to just
physically go to a place and say here i
am
and lay on the table and that's so easy
i think i heard
joe rogan say something about mma
fighters how
they nothing upsets them yeah like when
people like us lose our cell phones we
get all upset it ruins our day
these guys nothing upsets them because
they're facing death like on a daily
basis
basically things definitely upset me you
know like
like that's part of like the
self-centeredness like i get angry and
and be
and be immature and throw a tantrum like
i've noticed that a couple times lately
but nothing like it really scares me or
worries me you know like
for whatever reason you know like
getting having this be positive and
having to do whatever
happens after that or the risk of dying
that would come with that
doesn't scare me well i you know
listening to what you just told me i
think
you've gone from what most viewers
who've watched your other videos would
be
oh my god this guy is so much worse off
than all of us and i think where you're
i think where you're going to end up is
so much better off than all of us
so much healthier yeah
that would be awesome you know like like
having this finally be a win
like a long-term win down the road i
mean i don't even know what that would
look like
i can i could totally see it yeah but
but people do say
uh it's almost like a cliche but i
totally believe in it like this disease
this addiction disease and i know some
people don't think it's a disease and
who knows but like
legally it's a disease american medical
association definitely a thing
yeah so i mean
this is the only disease that like if
you recover from it
it leaves you off better than if you had
never had it at all
if that makes sense so i get through
this i could be
you know or any of us i'm like speaking
for any of us that are addicts
we get through it we wind up on the
other end better than if we had just
never been an addict in the first place
because of the growth and sort of like
what the humility and all that helping
others par
all that that comes along with
recovering so
i don't know yeah
let me ask you questions i that might be
it man no that's great you're incredible
i'm so happy appreciate you mark i'm so
happy we met yeah me too
and i i i see great things for you
i'm ready i'm worried about the cancer
yeah but i'm not worried about
everything else i think you're you're
the opposite of me so between the two of
us you're worried about the cancer
i'm worried about everything else no i
think you're i think you're in the right
place we're a good team
i feel really good about everything but
i'm glad you're taking care of them
yeah so i'll let you know that the
outcome on that excellent
and uh i'm looking forward to uh seeing
where you're at in uh
six months or wherever sure me too i'm
proud of you
thanks mark appreciate it thank you
patrick
oh it's so nice to talk to this patrick